for all its gross-out gags that made it
a favorite for the kids there's a whole
lot for grownup viewers to enjoy in Teen
Titans go from the Filmation references
to the 1980s power ballads here are the
things only adults notice about this
crazy DC show Teen Titans go to the
movies focuses on everyone's favorite
team of sidekicks but it's a delight for
any fan who loves the larger universe of
DC comics that might come as a surprise
though when you consider the cartoons a
well-deserved reputation for absurdity
for the most part that's a rep that the
Titans have earned it's not exactly the
intense drama of that man the animated
series but that doesn't mean a die-hard
fan won't love all the references in
jokes and tributes crammed into their
cinematic adventures 90-minute running
time in fact one of the most charming
pieces of the film is also the
fulfilment of one particularly dedicated
DC fans long-held desire that fan is
Nicolas Cage who finally got the chance
to play Superman on the big screen now
cage isn't your garden-variety superhero
fan he paid over two million dollars for
a pristine copy of Action Comics number
one the Man of Steel's historic first
appearance not only did he named his son
after Superman he skipped over Clark and
went straight to the deep cut Kryptonian
name of kal-el he's about as devoted as
any fan can be which made the collapse
of Superman lives the Tim Burton film in
which he was set to play the Big Blue
Boy Scout all the more devastating 20
years later however he finally got to
play the role in Teen Titans go to the
movies hey
I guess you aren't such GUP stirs after
all kids might not realize the
behind-the-scenes gag but that's a union
of fan and icon that every adult who has
obsessed over the idea of Nick Cage
fighting a giant robot spider could
appreciate it might not be Superman
lives and there's sadly no spider to be
found but it sure is better than nothing
season threes finally a lesson isn't
quite like any other episode of Teen
Titans go for one thing it's actually
educational maybe a little too
educational Robin takes the Titans on a
whirlwind journey through the world of
property investment because it's time
the team learned something practical and
what's more practical than real estate
thus the teens however reluctantly
learned about down payments rent control
and most importantly of all building
equity that last part in particular
becomes a lot more exciting once they
learn it's just a fancy way of saying
money equity is the amount of a property
usually Oh
it's the difference between your loan
balance and your properties market value
if you sold your property and paid on
the bank the value of your equity at the
point of the episode that it's boring
and adult centric isn't lost on kids who
get that Robin is a stuffy dweeb
enforcing a hilariously inappropriate
tone upon the show but what they can't
grasp is that Robin is actually giving
out some pretty good advice
finally a lesson is in fact a great
introduction to the rental market with
solid tips on how to improve your credit
score and how to save for retirement
sure the air horns that blare when Robin
celebrates all that equity finally
funding old people medication are
sarcastic but darn it if Watchers over
30 won't be nodding along decades later
perhaps some of the show's youngest fans
will look back and realize that Robins
lessons are the reason they became
Realtors or maybe they'll just feel
weird when they remember that Teen
Titans once bought an apartment building
and immediately evicted everyone to make
more money for a cartoon aimed at grade
schoolers Teen Titans go spends quite a
bit of time on romance generally
speaking it keeps things fairly tame but
there were entire episodes devoted to
Robin wanting to see Starfire in a
bikini beast boy drooling over ravens
legs and a whole lot of Looney tune
style wolf-whistling adult eyebrows
might raise at these pg-13 ish moments
but really that sort of borderline
risque content has a long history in
kids cartoons but every so often Teen
Titans go steps over the line witnessed
the scene from the first season episode
real magic in which Beast Boy waits on
Ravens bed clad only in his underwear
having set the mood with candles and a
scatter of rose petals she's not
interested but the implications of the
moment are clear and pretty adult kids
might not grasp the full meaning of the
scene but in the minds of many adults
it's better not to test that theory
in fact UK fans reported that the shot
was cut from their broadcast Teen Titans
go made its mission clear from the very
first episode silliness to the extreme
with a generous dollop of outright bad
taste but joke's bad puns extensive
mocking of Batman it's all fair game
many viewers especially kids loved it
for exactly those reasons but there have
always been a handful of folks who can't
stand its goofy approach to one of DCs
most beloved super teams especially the
fans of the slightly darker 2003 series
you are
curry of everything the world holds
sacred about heroes come on what is so
bad about being a little silly from time
to time while younger viewers might not
realize this Teen Titans go itself has
addressed those critics directly and
what have informally become known as the
hater episodes these episodes cast the
ultra nerd villain control freak as an
aggrieved fan of the Titans previous TV
incarnation and serve as a direct
response to the most vocally displeased
viewers in the fourth wall control freak
even placed clips from the 2003 cartoon
to compare the current team unfavorably
against only to have his fandom roundly
rebuffed still he remains undaunted
appearing again and again to taunt the
Titans with deleted scenes old-school
Superfriends style sequences and an
endless supply of complaints nitpicks
and rants he is in short the sort of
commentator who has been talking trash
about the series from day one and the
show misses no opportunity to make it
clear through him how they feel about
that segment of Titans fandom Slade
known in the comics by the over-the-top
name of Deathstroke the Terminator was a
long time coming to Teen Titans go he
was one of the major menaces of the
team's adventures in the comics back in
the 80s the most prominent villain in
the 2003 cartoon and an increasingly
major part of the DC universe as a whole
finally he returned to face his animated
archenemies in Teen Titans go to the
movies only to be mistaken for Deadpool
Deadpool Deadpool what I'm not going to
I thought Deadpool was a good guy why
does everybody think of Deadpool since
Deadpool's movie carried a hard-r rating
this gag was already meant more for
adults in the audience but there's a
whole other level of reference to this
joke only the most seasoned of Titans
fans grasp Deadpool and Deathstroke
there's some pretty striking
similarities but it's actually Marvel's
version that's ripping off Slade in fact
after seeing rob live fields designs
Deadpool's co-creator Fabian Nicieza
gave their new character the name Wade
Wilson an overt joke to Deathstroke's
named Slade Wilson none of that matters
to the Titans or their younger fans of
course but to the savvy adults in the
audience it's a joke decades in the
making the episode 40% 40% 20% unleashed
an awesome force upon the Teen Titans go
universe that's right we're talking
about cyborgs ultimate pump up Jam the
night begins to shine as
Cinthia to whatever the night beginning
to shine means its effect upon cyborgs
is so potent as to have become a bit of
a crutch but who could blame them when
exposed to its sheer 80s inspired power
the Titans transformed into radical
versions of themselves with gravity
defying hair artfully ripped costumes
and sweet motorcycles transport it to a
neon desert they cruise lost in the
sweet riffs that cyborgs treasured
cassette tape brings them so powerful as
this sequence that it not only
transformed cyborg into a not-so-subtle
tribute to Optimus Prime it spawned an
epic 4 episode arc it was called the day
the night stopped beginning to shine and
became dark even though it was the day
it's exactly as righteous as you're
imagining to a kid this is all extremely
cool you don't have to be born in the
80s to understand that heavy metal
dragons are awesome after all for the
adults in the audience though there's
another layer in the form of the show
spot-on parody of 1980 sci-fi down to
the smallest most radical detail the
Titans eighties transformations are
straight out of Mad Max and Voltron
their world like a fever dream from the
pages of heavy metal with all of it
sprinkled with glitter straight out of
Jem and the Holograms
what makes it even more hilarious for
older viewers is that the song isn't
actually from the 80s instead it was
written and recorded in 2005 as an
intentional throwback for Warner
Brothers in house music library when an
episode in season 2 came up a little
short the show's director threw in a
10-second clip of cyborg singing along
to the epic jams fans wound up loving it
and the rest was history and a surprise
appearance for the night begins to shine
on the Billboard charts 12 years after
it was recorded with this irresistible
groove Teen Titans go doesn't just poke
fun at the decade cyborg seems to love
so much it celebrates it by bringing its
best ideas to the floor and wrapping
them up in an absolute banger of a song
Batman isn't exactly a fearsome force of
justice and Teen Titans go he spends
most of his time giggling with
Commissioner Gordon serving as a
celebrity judge on Talent Search TV
shows and rocking out on electric guitar
not quite the Dark Knight of legend but
that's how Teen Titans go rules right no
one is as sleek cool and powerful within
its cartoon confines as they are in
other DC media Batman might be the
world's greatest detective and the hero
Gotham needs elsewhere but in Teen
Titans go he's Robin's weirdo man ciao
pseudo debt except when it comes to
background gags in these Batman's corner
of the universe is just as brutal and
ruthless as it has ever been but only
the sharp-eyed grown-up is likely to
catch it consider sidekick an episode
that sends the Titans to Gotham City the
scenes in the Batcave contain a massive
number of references to more serious
Batman stories lurking in the background
but nothing comes close to what's on the
middle shelf of Batman's display case
next to a photo of Batman and Robin
there stands a crowbar and an urn
labeled Robin - this is a reference to
the death of the second Robin Jason Todd
in the infamous 1988 storyline a death
in the family it's a blank and you miss
it moment but boy does it add a little
darkness to the fun bright world of Teen
Titans go for those who managed to catch
it Teen Titans go might have started out
life as a cartoon but it still takes a
few shots at DC's cinematic Ventures in
fact there might be no greater source of
teasing for the DC films especially
since the show made it into theaters and
Teen Titans go to the movies to begin
with there's the very premise of the
film itself in the age of the
omnipresent superhero movie Robin wants
one to call his own everyone else has
one so why can't he
Superman has plenty wonder woman admits
Hurst took a while but it's been made
Green Lantern even gets to join it
although he acknowledges that his team
cinematic outing wasn't quite as
successful as the others
there was a Green Lantern movie but we
don't we don't talk about that parodies
of cinematic Batman branding over the
years filled the screen from the bright
yellow of the Tim Burton era to the
brushed steel aesthetic of The Dark
Knight trilogy but nothing comes close
to topping the Batman vs Superman joke
that sees Batman and Superman growling
at each other about their mommies named
Teen Titans go might love the DC
Universe but that doesn't mean it won't
roast its own movies check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]